we know there's a new Stargate coin we
know they're trying to make a movie and
a TV series we know penguin and park are
involved but we now also know the Bad
Robot may also be involved
oh God
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
[Music]
so I share the news with you guys and I
shared the rumors that are here with you
guys even when I don't like them this is
one of those rumors that I'd like to
hide from I'd like to stick under a rock
and hide it and pretend it wasn't there
but unfortunately that's not how this
works and I have to share it with you
anyway so let's do a little bit of the
background so I was told a couple of
months ago and I told you guys that
Amazon were asking for pitches for the
new Stargate series they were looking
for a company to produce the series and
potentially a movie
so they asked lots of companies bad row
but we're one of the companies that came
back and pitched some ideas on how to
move forward to the franchise now I told
you guys that also Mark Ferguson Hawk
host piece company penguin and Parker
also pitched and they absolutely blew
Amazon Executives away according to the
people I speak to and contract
negotiations have already started and
how moving forwards with the new
franchise of Stargate now we also know
that Mark Ferguson hawkhostby are
developing a God of War series for
Amazon with The Wheel of Time showrunner
Rafe Judkins now Amazon like to work
with the same people and actually this
whole Stargate thing with Mark Fergus
happened because they Amazon actually
asked him what he would like to work on
and apparently according to insiders he
said Stargate so that's the way we're
moving forwards but we don't actually
know what role Mark Ferguson Hawk
hostby's company penguin and Parker will
take with the Stargate franchise now
when I heard that contractual stuff was
happening I might have got a little bit
over excited and we assumed that he
would be show running and actually
producing the project
but with cooler heads it's probably more
likely they won't actually show run and
that they're just developing the series
the same is to be honest they did with
the expanse and that they're doing with
God of War that they will act as
executive producers they will produce
some script and they will do the
development work on the project but they
don't actually show run they don't
actually manage and they don't actually
produce the television show that is far
more likely what they're going to be
doing with starting please like
subscribe and hit the Bell notification
if you are new to the channel so you
don't miss any of our new videos also if
you really want to support the channel
consider hitting the join button and
you'll get all of our Thursday videos 24
hours before anybody else all of the
links are in the description now I have
also heard that Amazon do have a few
little concerns about Mark Fergus
pulling off this project particularly
whether penguin and Parker can I'll have
the experience to pull off a movie
franchise as well as the TV series they
just don't have that experience even
though they've written big budget movies
they've never actually been executive
producers on such a project and Stargate
is a big project for Amazon they really
want this to be one of the big sci-fi
franchises along the lines of Star Wars
Star Trek Etc so they might be hedging
their Betsy and trying to find other
production companies to work alongside
penguin in a park and now to be honest I
always expected that anyway like I said
when I announced this I always expected
Stargate to have two or three production
companies for example they'll probably
bring in a production company that
specializes in the CGI they'll have to
bring in a production company that
actually owns Studios that can
physically actually make the show
because that's how Amazon do it it is
also one of the big reasons why Brad
Wright didn't actually get the gig in
the first place because Amazon prefer to
do it like this they prefer to bring in
companies that will produce it for them
rather than an individual visual that
then will like create a production
company around the project like Brad
Wright did for Stargate now I was also
told back when Bad Robot did Pitch for
the TV series a few months ago that it
didn't actually go very well and that
they were out of the running that they
were not going to be making Stargate
but then just before Christmas the rumor
came round again now I dismissed it
initially but I've now heard it from two
or three completely separate sources so
it's hard not to start listening also
I've heard from one source that is very
reliable that actually this might have
been going a bit further than just a
conversation and might actually be going
into contract negotiations as well now
this Source isn't certain because
they've not had full access to the
information but they believe the current
negotiations are more around a movie of
Stargate than the actual TV series
so right guys we've got a couple of
possibilities here now I'm going to say
we're speculating a little bit because
we've only got snapshots of information
but
there's a couple of possibilities
so they could be as I say just using
corcos beat and Mark focus's company
penguin in a Parker to do the
development work and then somebody
within Bad Robot will step up and be the
showrunner not JJ Abrams but it's a
reasonably large company so let's hope
somebody else
um but somebody else will step up and
penguin and Parker will be the
development side and Bad Robot will be
the production side now I don't have a
major problem with that and by that I
mean the TV series and the movies
um together working together right I
don't like the changing Abram Star Trek
movies I've said this many times on this
channel before they're not Star Trek but
they are actually quite good films
they're entertaining and you can't argue
that they're not beautifully made
they're very pretty films
even the Star Wars movies that JJ Abrams
got involved in now again we can argue
about the story and the Canon pissing
all over it etc etc
but they are well made pretty movies
so if Amazon basically saying to penguin
and Parker you do the development you do
the story you do the scripts and JJ
Abrams you just make them look nice I
don't have a problem with that the other
thing is though that actually Bad Robot
have produced TV shows in the past like
Fringe for example that I absolutely
adored so they are capable of making
good TV
whether they will or not yeah is a bit
of a concern but as I say if they leave
the actual hard work in the hands of the
expanse guys who do have a full plate
already
and just make a TV show that looks good
then this could actually be a match made
in heaven and something that we
shouldn't worry about too much
the other possibility is that just
bringing in Bad Robot to produce the
movies because penguin and Parker
doesn't have the experience to do that
so penguin and Parker will focus on the
TV series and JT Abrams will be allowed
to run the movies
now I have more concerns about that
because we know what JJ Abrams does when
he gets a franchise and he gets free
reign he creates Star Trek now that was
a problem
but the TV series the movies are gonna
have to
merge together aren't they they're going
to have to be able to exist in the same
universe so JJ Abrams will not be able
to mess around with it too much
he would have to sit in line with
whatever they do in the TV series so
kind of by default Mark Ferguson hall
goes to be still kind of in charge
unless they let J.J Abrams and Bad Robot
do the movie first and then tell
penguin and a Parker that you've got to
go with what they've done which would be
a problem so I have got concerns about
that but look at the end of the day we
don't actually know what the plan is yet
but How likely do I think this is well
Bad Robot has lots of projects on the go
at the moment they had a big deal with
Warner Brothers to produce lots of
different TV shows they also had um
through Warner Brothers a plan to do a
Speed Racer TV series that was going to
go straight to apple plus now it looks
like the speed racist TV series is
actually still reasonably on course but
almost all of the rest of the projects
they've got planned with Warner Brothers
they've got massive question marks over
them
portal the movie based on the game has
been in development for over a year and
nobody's really said much about it for
about a year now and more really
um it does seem to be stuck in
development hell and as we know zazlaf
the new CEO of Warner Brothers Discovery
is culling an awful lot of projects one
of the other projects that um bad Robert
was supposed to be producing was an
Untitled Superman movie
at the moment it looks like that's got a
big question mark over it too I mean
that's just been Fair let's be honest
it's almost certainly been scrapped the
only projects they've really got at the
moment that are probably safe are the
two Batman animated movies and TV series
that they're planning
so other than that every single project
that they've got penned in for the next
two years
is up for debate on whether they're
actually going to be like to make it or
not other than Speed Racer
so they would seem to have time on their
hands so they have the time on their
hands they do have the experience of
making very large very high value
production movies for franchises they've
done worked on Star Wars and Star Trek
too
limited success they've also have a vast
experience working on very large TV
series
Bad Robot on paper is a very sensible
production company for Amazon to go to
now obviously about having working very
strongly with Warner Brothers but I do
wonder if they might be looking to
switch allegiances particularly
considering that actually if a lot of
these projects that I've been talking
about are going to be scrapped that's
six or seven projects in total
um I I can imagine as a company you
might go well how much do we really want
to work with Warner Brothers in the
future so if that is going to happen
they are going to start to move towards
and try to work with Amazon more it
would make sense so what do I think
I think this is probably true
um I from the sources I speak to I know
that there are very least the
conversations are happening whether it
then comes to pass or not we won't know
probably until the new year
one thing I do think though is that we
were expecting a January announcement on
this now I know from again my sources
that lots of marketing meetings they
really wanted to announce this for when
MGM plus was announced um as part of the
launch for MGM plus which would have
been the middle of January
from what I'm hearing and where we're at
with the development I just can't see
that date happening we're talking about
three weeks it seems unlikely that I
think the most will get if we do get an
announcement in mid-January is the
intention to develop a series
I don't think we'll get more than that I
actually think it's going to be more
like the spring just from what I'm
hearing and where we seem to be now
again Amazon particularly like to
announce TV shows when the development
work is done when they're actually 100
certain they're going to go ahead with
it which is another point we have to
make they're still they still haven't
signed this off yet so it still could
not happen and I believe it takes three
or four months to do the development
work on a series like this so I would
say March April
but let's see what happens
this is a very fluid situation it keeps
changing it's maddening
um but guys we are getting close and
we're the closest we've ever got to
getting the Stargate franchise back
whether you want a movie first or
whether you want a TV series and then a
movie or you don't want a movie at all
is irrelevant really because we don't
even know if we're getting anything yet
and getting worried about Bad Robot
being involved really is kind of the
same let's worry if it actually gets
announced first and then we'll start
talking about really our concerns about
Bad Robot being involved if they are
but guys get in the comments and tell me
exactly what you think is this news you
kind of expected is this news that
surprised you or is this something that
is really concerning you or do you
actually like me look at the back
catalog of things that Bad Robot have
done
and think well you know there's some
good stuff in there let's hope the
people that did that turn up are not the
people that did a few of the other
projects
get in the comments tell me exactly what
you think
as always please like subscribe hit that
Bell notification and if you want to
support the channel and become a fully
fledged side tracker consider hitting
the join button where you will get our
Thursday videos 24 hours before anybody
else
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
[Music]